hey 42 here it's amazing what ridiculous
stories get passed around the table at a
dinner party or when you're out drinking
with your friends I'm sure you've heard
a few gruesome tales that sound too
horrible to be true
most urban legends are no more than
Chinese whispers told over and over
again until no one can actually remember
if there's any truth to the damn thing
but very occasionally it turns out that
one of these creepy tales is actually
completely true and the real-life
version is more horrific than you could
ever imagine if you spend long enough in
western Pennsylvania you will
undoubtedly hear the spine-chilling
tales of the Green Man according to the
urban legends he was a horrific ly
disfigured man with no face and glowing
green skin the Green Man apparently
wandered the streets of Pennsylvania
every night drivers would often report
seeing this terrifying figure at the
side of the road in the dead of the
night turns out the real story is
actually one of misfortune and
loneliness the Green Man was not a
monster at all but a man named Raymond
Robinson when Robinson was 8 years old
he was attempting to view a bird's nest
and was electrocuted by some electrical
lines of a nearby tram line Robinson
narrowly escaped death but was less
severely disfigured he lost his nose
eyes and ear and one of his arms the
skin on his face was so badly damaged by
the shock that it glowed with a green
hue hence his nickname of the Green Man
Robinson walked the roads of western
Pennsylvania every night because he
could not go outside during the day
without causing mass hysteria next up is
the shadowy figure I'm sure that
everyone has been witness to this urban
legend at some point in most people's
lives they've seen a shadowy figure dart
across the room out of the corner of
their eye as if someone is there but
when they turn around nothing
it's the oldest urban legend in the book
and stories of mysterious shadowy
figures have been told all throughout
history
but for one man in Fukuoka Japan this
urban legend turned out to be true the
man apparently lived alone in an
apartment he kept telling people how we
saw shadowy figures moving around his
apartment at the corner of his eye he
swore that things kept going missing
from his apartment the man claimed that
someone was eating his food and moving
things around he reported an
overwhelming sense that another being
was present with him and that he was far
from alone he was absolutely correct
one day he set up a hidden camera in the
corner of his apartment and to the man's
horror he captured footage of a woman
slithering out of his cupboard and using
his apartment as if it was hers eating
his food I'm using his belongings even
taking showers the creepiest part of it
all is that when he watched the footage
back the woman was still in his cupboard
only a few meters behind him the woman
turned out to be 58 year old tatsuko
horikawa she was homeless and admitted
to the police that she had been secretly
living in the man's apartment without
his knowledge for the past year
there's an old folklore called Bloody
Mary that goes like this if you turn off
all the lights
then light a candle and stir into a
mirror and chant Bloody Mary three times
the face of Queen Mary the first of
England will supposedly appear in the
mirror with a terrifyingly evil
expression in some versions of this
urban legend she apparently appears in
the mirror holding a dead baby in her
arms which may be a reference to the
number of miscarriages that Queen
married the first heart now this may
seem far-fetched but there is some truth
to this urban legend and oddly enough
some science to a lot of people who try
this do actually see something peculiar
in the mirror and many perceive it to be
the face of Queen Mary the first but
it's not what you're actually seeing is
your own face heavily distorted due to
something called a Caputo effect this
effect occurs because of sensory
deprivation our eyes are being deprived
of light but our brain is trying its
hardest to make out the face in the
mirror
this causes the brains facial
recognition system to malfunction the
result of this is that what we see is a
distorted version of our own face which
in poor lighting could be misconstrued
to be the face of Queen Mary because
most people who attempt this are
expecting to see the face of an evil
queen that's what the brain makes us
sick our brain is deprived of visual
information so naturally our imagination
fills in the gaps there's an infamous
story that many parents have told their
poor children in an attempt to scare the
living daylights out of them the legend
goes that a couple stayed in a hotel
room and complained about a putrid smell
but when the hotel staff couldn't find
anything out of the ordinary they stayed
there anyway later they found that the
cause of the smell was a dead body
stuffed into the mattress that's bloody
nasty but it has happened in fact it
happens a lot more commonly than you
might think
cases of dead bodies in hotel mattresses
have been reported in Las Vegas Atlantic
City California and Florida a recent
case occurred in 2010 when a Memphis
woman was missing for two months before
she was finally found dead under the
mattress of a hotel room where she had
been staying in the two months whilst
her corpse had been rotting away under
the mattress the hotel had rented the
room to five different people and none
of them fought to investigate the
strange smell the room had also been
cleaned by hotel staff several times
during those two months I guess the
cleaners just took one look at the dead
body and four I don't get paid enough
for this
according to urban legend there's an
unnerving tale of a family who moved
into a new house the story goes that a
rancid smelling jet-black water came out
of all the taps in their new home when
they investigated they were horrified to
discover that the cause of the
Blackwater was a decomposing human body
in the water tank
it makes one skin crawl to think that
this could actually be true but it is
however the real story is so much worse
because it happened
in a hotel not someone's home in 2013
for a whole 19 days hundreds of guests
at the Cecil Hotel in Los Angeles were
bathing in brushing their teeth with and
even drinking the water from a tank on
the rooftop that contained the
decomposing corpse of a college student
named ELISA lab seriously guys just stay
away from hotels they're bad news we've
all heard the horror story two people
who have been buried Six Feet Under
presuming they were dead but they
weren't other tales just urban mists or
is there some truth to it unfortunately
it's true and not only is it true but it
happened literally hundreds if not
thousands of times in the late 19th
century when the medical profession
hadn't yet fully developed during this
time people were mistakenly buried alive
quite regularly
there were 219 known and reported cases
of people being buried alive during the
late 19th century well that's just the
ones that were later dug up only to find
scratch marks on the inside of the
coffin where they had tried to get out
just think how many more people this
happened to without anyone's knowledge
because you know once you bury someone
it's usually a permanent arrangement you
don't usually make regular checkups to
see if granddad is still alive down
there
in fact this happened with such
regularity that wealthy people would
invest in safety coffins before they
died to prevent premature burial these
specially built coffins had a device
that allowed a supposedly deceased
person to ring a bell above the surface
if they were still alive down there some
people believe this is where the phrases
Saved by the Bell and dead ringer come
from but there's still some debate going
on over this many designs of these
safety coffins were patented during the
18th and 19th century and they sold in
their thousands you can still buy more
modern versions of safety coffins today
for the ultra paranoid out there when
you went on the haunted house ride at
the carnival as a child did your parents
ever tell you that the paper mache
corpse hanging gob was actually a real
human corpse well in at least one
fairground this turned out
to be gruesomely true in 1976 a camera
crew was filming an episode of the Six
Million Dollar Man in the new pike
amusement park in Long Beach California
the crew was moving a hanging man prop
while preparing to film inside the
haunted house when they accidentally
knocked off one of its arms to their
horror this prop wasn't made of paper
mache because inside they found real
human bones turns out the whole thing
was a real human cadaver hung up for all
the little kiddies to see it wasn't any
ordinary corpse Eva it turns out that
the body was that of criminal mastermind
Elmer mccurdy who was shot and killed
whilst robbing a train in 1911 his body
was embalmed by the local Undertaker the
Undertaker was so pleased with his work
that he put it on display in his funeral
home to show off to clients like some
kind of horrible McCobb portfolio of
dead bodies McCurry's corpse remained on
display in the Undertaker's funeral home
for several years until one day
McCurdy's brothers showed up and claimed
the corpse turns out these guys weren't
his brothers at all but carnival
promoters who were too lazy to make
their own artificial props for the
haunted house McCurdy's corpse went on a
whirlwind carnival tour all across
America scaring the holy hell out of
little kids everywhere it went until it
was finally discovered by the film crew
in Long Beach California and he was
finally buried there's hundreds of urban
legends about people who get a creepy
crawly inside their ear and then the
book lays its eggs inside their skull
well I truly am sorry to tell you this
because after hearing it you probably
will never go outside again but it does
happen it happens very rarely but one
recent case happened in 2032 Rachelle
Harris from Derby England she was on the
flight back from a holiday in Peru when
she began to develop headaches she
ignored them until a few hours later
when she started to get shooting pains
down the side of her face
then to her absolute horror she started
to hear scratching sounds inside her own
head the next morning she woke up to a
pillow soaked in fluid which was pouring
out of her ear Harris went to the
hospital in Derby after a brain x-ray
the doctor told her that she had maggots
living inside her ear canal at which
point she instantly burst into tears
rightfully sir the maggots had burrowed
a hole 12 millimeters deep into her ear
canal luckily they hadn't yet reached
her brain and caused any serious damage
Harris had minor surgery to remove the
muggers the surgeon found a colony of
eight large flesh-eating maggots inside
her ear after laboratory research it was
discovered that the maggots must have
hatched in her ear after a screwworm fly
had flown into her ear and laid his eggs
while she was in Peru so there's
anything you can take away from this
video it's that if you ever go to Peru
cover your ears
also don't stay in hotels ever check all
your cupboards in your house because
there's probably someone living in there
oh and if you ever go to a carnival
don't touch the props thanks for the
view subscribe for more 42